Profª. Tamar Gendler:
Então, a aula de hoje é
sobre a questão que envolve o
desafio proposto por Glauco
na história do anel de Giges.
A pergunta é:
que tipo de motivações temos
para agir moralmente
e que expectativas devemos ter a
respeito dos que nos rodeiam,
sobre se eles agem dessa forma –
por razões intrínsecas
à motivação moral ou
simplesmente porque querem
aparentar de um determinado jeito?
Eu quero começar contando um pouco
sobre a pessoa extraordinária
por trás do diálogo de A República,
do qual lemos uns trechos para hoje.
É difícil calcular a
influência de Platão
na tradição intelectual ocidental.
Não há nenhuma pessoa
educada no mundo ocidental
nos últimos 2.500 anos que não
tenha sido influenciada
de alguma forma pelo pensamento e
pela estrutura de entendimento
que Platão nos proporcionou
há cerca de 2.500 anos.
Platão era uma figura
extremamente interessante.
Ele nasceu numa família
aristocrática de Atenas.
Alguns creem que ele era descendente
de um dos reis atenienses,
mas independentemente disso, o
certo é que a sua família
estava entre os líderes da
sociedade política ateniense.
Vários de seus tios formaram
parte de um golpe de estado
realizado muitos anos antes de
Platão atingir a maturidade.
E a expectativa para tipos como
Platão era a de que eles iriam
para a área cívica ou para o governo,
seriam uma liderança pública.
Era como se ele fosse um Kennedy,
um Bush ou um Clinton.
Ele vinha de uma família com
uma longa história
de engajamento político.
E a suposição era de que ele se
tornaria politicamente engajado.
Mas, curiosamente, por razões sobre as
quais há grandes especulações,
Platão foi influenciado por um homem
cerca de 30 anos mais velho
chamado Sócrates, que, nos
retratos que temos dele,
parecia muito com o próprio Platão.
Sócrates era um provocador.
Ele vagava por Atenas e
pedia que as pessoas
refletissem sobre as suas
responsabilidades.
Pedia que elas pensassem sobre a
natureza de coisas fundamentais
como a justiça, a verdade, a
realidade, a amizade,
o amor e a honestidade.
Ele pedia que as pessoas
refletissem sobre a opinião comum
e se perguntassem quais, das
coisas que elas acreditavam,
estavam bem fundamentadas e quais, das
eram simplesmente questões
de opinião recebida.
E, em parte, por causa
dessa provocação,
Sócrates foi condenado à
morte em 399 a.C.
Platão tinha por volta de 30 anos
quando o seu grande mestre morreu.
E ele descreve a história do
julgamento em que Sócrates foi acusado
de corromper a juventude de Atenas
num diálogo extraordinário
conhecido como Apologia de Sócrates.
E o legado deixado pela Apologia é
algo parecido com o legado
que os Evangelhos fornecem
sobre a vida de Jesus.
É a história de uma pessoa disposta
a morrer por uma questão de
princípio, tornando-se um tropo para
a civilização ocidental.
Numa pintura extraordinária que é
possível ver ao visitar o Metropolitan
Museum, em Nova York, há uma
representação da morte de Sócrates.
Aqui está Sócrates, bebendo
do cálice de cicuta,
que o leva à morte.
Aqui estão os seus
discípulos, incluindo
Platão,
serenamente à beira da cama, e
Crito, segurando a sua perna.
Subindo as escadas aqui, é
possível ver algumas
outras figuras indo embora.
Mas o que é extraordinário nesta
imagem é que ela foi pintada
em 1787 por um dos artistas
envolvidos na Revolução Francesa.
Ela foi apresentada a Thomas
Jefferson, que a admirava muito.
E uma das coisas impressionantes
sobre a composição é que,
de certa forma, ela ecoa a famosa
pintura de Leonardo da Vinci,
A Última Ceia. Aqueles que estão
familiarizados com a arte sabem
que Jesus se senta no centro da
mesa, rodeado por discípulos.
Considerando que essa é uma
história de morte por causa da fé,
a história de Sócrates é uma
história de morte por causa da razão.
E a ideia de uma vida com base nos
princípios, registrada
por discípulos que podem explicar
a motivação dessa vida,
a ideia de que isso pode influenciar
milhares de anos de história
e inspirar a mudança política e o
compromisso com os princípios,
é um dos legados deixados por Platão.
Depois da morte de Sócrates,
Platão se dedicou a uma
vida de aprendizagem,
e em 385 a.C.
começou o que muitos chamam a
1ªuniversidade ou academia
do mundo ocidental.
Nessa academia, Platão treinou
muitos dos pensadores
da antiga Atenas,
incluindo Aristóteles,
que leremos na semana que vem.
Enquanto esteve lá, Platão compôs uma
série de obras que perduraram.
Entre elas está A República,
que lemos trechos para hoje.
E aqui está um bonito
manuscrito do século 3
de A República, um dos
milhares de documentos
descobertos em Oxirrinco, no Egito,
há cerca de um século.
Eu coloquei a referência ali em cima,
portanto os que estiverem
intrigados podem ir e ler sobre
a história dos papiros de Oxirrinco,
uma das mais incríveis
histórias de detetive
sobre a descoberta de um enorme
tesouro de documentos.
Como eu disse, há apenas um século;
muitos deles foram recuperados
durante e após a Primeira
Guerra Mundial. Então,
A República, como já mencionei, é
um dos cerca de 30 diálogos
escritos por Platão.
Vocês devem ter notado no
decorrer da leitura,
como o guia de leitura indicava,
que ele não está escrito
como um tratado.
Está escrito na forma de uma conversa.
E com exceção de algumas
cartas que temos,
quase todo o trabalho de Platão
está em forma de diálogo.
E eles abordam quase todos os temas
filosóficos imagináveis.
A natureza do conhecimento, a
natureza da verdade,
a natureza do amor, a natureza da
amizade e assim por diante.
A República, em particular,
está focada na questão
da estruturação da sociedade
para permitir que os seres
humanos prosperem.
E o trabalho, herdado por nós,
está organizado em 10 livros,
dos quais leremos trechos do 2º livro
e a maior parte do 10º.
Na parte em que estamos,
nós escutamos uma conversa
entre 3 personagens.
Um deles é o professor de
Platão, Sócrates,
o sujeito com o nariz arrebitado
que eu mostrei antes no slide;
e os outros dois são os irmãos de
Platão: Glauco e Adimanto.
E a conversa que escutamos ocorre
primeiro entre Sócrates
e Glauco e depois entre
Sócrates e Adimanto.
Mas, é claro, nós não estamos
lendo os papiros de Oxirrinco.
Nem mesmo estamos lendo, como
alguns alunos de Yale estão
neste semestre, o texto no
grego original.
Há um seminário que está sendo
oferecido no meu departamento
sobre A República de Platão
em que eles estão lendo o
texto em grego antigo.
E há uma colaboração extraordinária
Yale-Londres, de uma década,
em que uma semana por ano os
professores de Yale
e os de Londres se reúnem para ler
um livro de A República.
Portanto, este é um livro que
se lê a sério aqui.
Nós, no entanto, temos a sorte de
estar lendo uma edição,
que eu pedi que todos comprassem,
que se parece com esta.
Eu quero explicar a vocês porque eu
pedi para comprar o livro,
sendo que, como muitos já
devem ter notado,
a tradução de A República,
uma tradução feita
no final do século 19 por
Benjamin Jowett,
está disponível na internet.
E eu só quero comentar algumas coisas
sobre o valor que existe em obter
edições de livros projetadas
para ajudar os alunos a se
envolverem com o material.
Na cópia de A República que eu
pedi para vocês comprarem
há um extenso material introdutório.
Há notas de rodapé
extraordinariamente úteis.
Há uma bibliografia comentada no
material preparatório que aponta
os livros a buscar caso você
esteja interessado em Platão.
Há um índice incrivelmente valioso.
E nas margens está o que eu
comentei com vocês,
a paginação Stephanus,
que permite encontrar a referência
em qualquer outra tradução.
Bom, vamos agora para a
parte substancial
do material de hoje.
O que Glauco, irmão de
Platão, está tentando fazer
no decorrer de sua
conversa com Sócrates?
Há 3 perguntas que Glauco
quer responder.
Na 1ª, ele quer dizer alguma
coisa sobre a natureza
e origem da justiça.
Como as pessoas vêm a se
comportar de maneira cooperativa
e do que falamos quando falamos
sobre as normas de justiça?
Esse é um tema que vamos discutir
quando chegarmos a Hobbes
e, por isso, eu não vou
dizer nada mais hoje
sobre o argumento oferecido por Glauco.
Em vez disso, eu quero focar 2 coisas:
A 2ª e a 3ª questões de Glauco.
A 1ª é a afirmação de Glauco
que as pessoas agem com
justiça a contragosto.
Que a única razão pela qual as
pessoas agem conforme
as leis da moralidade
é porque, assim, elas vão
ganhar uma boa reputação.
E a 2ª afirmação de Glauco
é que elas estão certas ao fazer isso.
Portanto, o texto começa com um
contraste fundamental.
Algo que é útil,
não só no contexto da discussão
de Glauco sobre a justiça,
mas essencial em toda a obra de Platão
– e esse é o contraste entre:
como as coisas aparentam
e como as coisas são.
É uma percepção
crucial reconhecer que
aparentar e ser pode estar separado
e que, em alguns casos, a
nossa preocupação é com como as
coisas aparentam, enquanto
em outros casos a nossa preocupação
é com como as coisas são.
Desse modo, o texto começa
com um desafio que Glauco
propõe a Sócrates. Ele diz:
você quer aparentar nos convencer
de que é melhor ser justo que injusto
ou você realmente quer nos convencer?
E, claramente, o objetivo de
Sócrates é o último.
Ele quer se engajar na
verdadeira persuasão.
Esse tema de aparentar versus ser
é retomado por Glauco,
que pergunta a Sócrates
se existe valor em ser justo
ou se o valor da justiça
trata apenas de aparentar ser assim.
Portanto, encontramos um
contraste nas páginas iniciais
entre 3 tipos de valor que
as coisas podem ter.
As coisas podem ser
intrinsecamente valiosas
– como fins em si mesmas,
valiosas para o que elas são.
Sócrates dá o exemplo aqui de
coisas como a alegria
e os prazeres inofensivos.
Essas são coisas que valorizamos
não pelo que elas oferecem a mais;
as valorizamos como fins em si mesmas.
Há, por outro lado,
as coisas que são meramente
instrumentalmente valiosas.
Coisas que são valiosas como meios.
Coisas que são valiosas para nos
permitirem fazer outra coisa
ou para aparentarem ser algo particular.
E nessa categoria estão coisas como
o dinheiro, que é valioso,
lembrem-se sempre, não
como um fim em si,
mas como um meio para outros fins.
E, por exemplo, coisas que
parecem perigosas.
Aquilo que você tenta fazer
num sentido evolutivo,
ou como uma nação, é para evitar
que outras pessoas a ataquem,
não importa se você é perigoso.
O que importa é que você
pareça perigoso.
E existem, é claro,
as coisas que são valiosas
para ambos os casos.
Coisas como – Sócrates
chama de visão –
as que valorizamos tanto porque
nos permitem fazer coisas
quanto porque trazem
prazer em si mesmas.
Ou saúde. Ou aprendizagem.
Ou conhecimento.
E o que Glauco e Sócrates
estão disputando
é em que categoria se
encaixa a justiça.
Se tivéssemos os nossos clickers,
esta seria a chance de
vocês participarem
marcando em qual categoria
Glauco pensa que está
a justiça e em qual categoria
Sócrates pensa que ela está.
Mas, no nosso último dia
sem tecnologia,
vou pedir que vocês levantem as mãos.
Em qual categoria
– intrinsecamente valiosa,
instrumentalmente valiosa ou ambas –
Glauco relaciona a justiça?
Quantos acham que ele pensa
que a justiça é apenas
intrinsecamente valiosa?
[pausa]
Quantos acham que ele pensa
que ela é meramente
instrumental valiosa?
[pausa]
E quantos acham que ele
pensa que são ambas?
[pausa]
Por outro lado, Sócrates.
Intrinsecamente valiosa?
[pausa]
Instrumentalmente valiosa?
Ambas?
[pausa]
Portanto, é uma disputa entre eles.
Ambos supõem que existe um
valor ao parecer justo,
mas a disputa entre eles é sobre se,
além disso, existe um
valor em ser justo.
Será que importa que você
realmente aja de uma maneira justa
ou o que importa apenas é que você
aparente agir de forma justa?
A fim de responder a essa pergunta,
Glauco, como um personagem
de A República,
faz uso de uma técnica
que é e se tornou
uma das técnicas fundamentais
no pensamento filosófico.
É basicamente
uma aplicação do método
científico para a nossa ideia.
Se você está tentando descobrir o
que faz uma semente crescer
– ela precisa de terra,
precisa de água, precisa de
luz, precisa de ar,
precisa que você cante
melodiosamente quando passa?
–, o que você faz é realizar
um experimento controlado
e argumentar:
Se a semente tem água, mas não
tem terra, ela cresce?
Se a semente tem ar, mas não
há canção, ela cresce?
Dessa forma, Glauco se envolve numa
série de exercícios imaginativos
em perguntar o que as pessoas
fariam se o comportamento justo
se divorciasse de suas
consequências típicas.
Ele pede para imaginar
alguém que aja tanto de forma
justa quanto injusta.
E pensar quais seriam as
motivações dessa pessoa
se as consequências fossem diferentes.
Em casos normais, se você agir
moralmente, você é notado
como agindo moralmente, e se
você agir de forma imoral,
você é notado como agindo imoralmente.
O que ele pede para considerar na
história do anel de Giges,
relatada na última aula,
é como as pessoas agiriam
se fossem notadas de forma idêntica,
independentemente da forma como elas
genuinamente se comportam.
Se o seu ato de imoralidade fosse
invisível para o mundo,
se você pudesse se comportar
de forma imoral sem que
ninguém o visse, de modo que a
reputação permanecesse incólume,
como você se comportaria?
A sugestão de Glauco com a
história do anel de Giges é que,
sob essas circunstâncias,
você se comportaria como
uma pessoa injusta.
Mas no caso dessa
história não convencer,
ele conta uma 2ª história
após o anel de Giges.
É a história da inversão, e
ele diz o seguinte:
Vamos supor que a pessoa
que age com justiça
seja notada por todos que agem
injustamente e que a pessoa
que age injustamente seja notada
como agindo com justiça.
Você continuaria se comportando
de acordo com os padrões
de moralidade tendo a reputação
oposta ligada a você?
Podemos contrastar essa
questão sobre a moralidade
com 2 casos, em que parece claro
no 1º que valorizamos
algo meramente instrumental e em
que parece claro no 2º
que valorizamos algo
intrínseco e instrumental.
Portanto, se o ato em que você
está envolvido é tomar
um medicamento repugnante e se, em
circunstâncias normais,
quando você toma o
remédio, você melhora
e quando você não toma,
você segue doente,
então se quiser melhorar,
presumivelmente, você vai tomar o
remédio.
Num cenário de Giges, onde
independentemente de tomar o
medicamente,
você melhora, você não vai
estar disposto a tomá-lo.
E, certamente, num cenário invertido,
onde se você toma o remédio,
você segue doente e se você não
tomá-lo, você melhora,
você não vai estar disposto a
tomar o medicamento.
Quando as coisas são de valor
meramente instrumental,
podemos ler a motivação fora
das consequências.
A questão é esta: a justiça é
como tomar um medicamento,
algo que valorizamos por causa
de um fim que ela produz
e não por causa do próprio remédio em
si, ou é mais como a visão?
Vamos supor que, como ocorre em
circunstâncias normais,
quando você vê, você tem a
experiência visual do mundo,
e quando você se envolve
numa atividade motora,
você não se choca com as coisas.
Porque eu posso ver este objeto, sou
capaz de regular o meu corpo
de tal forma que eu não bata nele.
Num cenário do anel de Giges,
eu não preciso ver para ser
capaz de evitar a colisão.
Parece claro para mim que, nesse caso,
eu ainda assim prefiro ter visão,
mesmo se eu pudesse obter
as consequências de ver sem tê-la.
E o que eu faria no caso
inverso, em que eu pudesse
ter tanto a visão quanto a
capacidade de evitar objetos,
ou a capacidade de evitar
objetos e não a visão...
eu não sei como responder.
Portanto, o desafio que Glauco
apresenta é o seguinte:
A moralidade é, para você, algo
meramente como tomar um remédio?
Você se comporta moralmente
para ter a reputação
de se comportar moralmente ou
você se comporta moralmente
porque a moralidade, sendo capaz de ver,
é algo valiosa em si mesma para você
e valiosa para você por causa das
consequências que ela produz?
Esse é o desafio de A
República de Platão.
E nas próximas aulas
ouviremos algumas respostas
que são oferecidas ao
desafio de Glauco.
Eu quero passar agora ao
2º texto de hoje,
um texto do psicólogo
contemporâneo Daniel Batson
que aborda a questão da integridade
moral e da hipocrisia moral
a partir de uma perspectiva
psicológica empírica.
A pergunta de Batson é: o objetivo
das pessoas é ser moral
ou o objetivo das pessoas é
apenas aparentarem ser assim?
Baston parece um pouco diferente
de Platão e Sócrates.
Ele é um homem vivo. Ensina na
Universidade de Kansas.
Possui, inclusive, uma impressora. E
na obra que lemos para hoje,
temos uma descrição dos estudos
empíricos que Batson fez
sobre como as pessoas se
comportam quando elas pensam
que não estão sendo observadas.
Como é que elas interpretam as
ações delas para si mesmas
e quais os fatores que, caso haja,
as levam a se comportar
de um jeito mais honesto? Batson
apresenta aos indivíduos
um cenário experimental muito simples.
As pessoas que participam dos
experimentos entram no laboratório
e escutam que o trabalho delas é
decidir qual das duas tarefas
querem que seja atribuída a elas
e qual será atribuída
a uma 2ª pessoa, que
elas não conhecem.
Uma das tarefas é
divertida e interessante
e a cada resposta correta você
recebe um bilhete de loteria
em que é possível ganhar uma
certa quantia de dinheiro.
A outra tarefa é descrita como sendo
chata e cada resposta correta
não dá direito a nada.
Dizem então às pessoas: você
pode optar pela diversão,
pela tarefa interessante com a chance
da loteria, e a tarefa chata
sem loteria para a outra pessoa;
ou você pode escolher para a outra
pessoa a tarefa divertida
e interessante e a tarefa chata
para você, sem loteria.
O que os psicólogos chamam de VD,
ou variável dependente
– a coisa à qual Batson está
procurando –, é a porcentagem
de vezes que as pessoas escolhem a
tarefa positiva para elas
e a tarefa neutra para as outras.
Se estivéssemos fazendo isso por acaso,
se literalmente estivéssemos
jogando uma moeda,
quantas vezes a tarefa
positiva seria atribuída?
Quantas vezes a pessoa escolheria
a tarefa positiva para ela mesma?
Multiplique o número de dedos
por 10 e assim teríamos a
porcentagem de vezes.
Numa mão, você tem: 50%. Portanto,
se você se limitar apenas
a jogar uma moeda, 50% das vezes
você acabará com a tarefa
positiva; 50% das vezes, a outra
pessoa acabará com a tarefa
positiva. Isso é uma das coisas
que Batson mede no estudo.
A outra coisa que Batson mede é o
valor do ponto que as pessoas
atribuem a si mesmas sobre o
quão moral foi a ação.
Se elas acham que a ação delas
foi perfeitamente moral
realizando a tarefa, então
elas se dão um 9.
Se elas acham que a ação foi
perfeitamente imoral
realizando a tarefa, elas se dão um 1.
Portanto, é isso que Batson mede.
Esse é o termo número 1 da
psicologia: variável dependente.
Aquilo que você está buscando
para ver as diferenças entre
os seus estudos. Quem daqui já
fez cadeiras de Psicologia,
tem amigos que fizeram um
curso de Psicologia,
sabe que quando os estudos de
psicologia são conduzidos,
os indivíduos são apresentados
àquilo que chamam de condições.
Ou seja, uma coisa acontece com eles
ou outra coisa acontece com eles.
O feijão que eu descrevi no
estudo de ciência pode estar
na condição onde ele tenha
água e terra, sem ar,
ou pode estar na condição onde tenha
terra e canção, sem água.
Da mesma forma, as pessoas da
experiência de Batson
podem estar num caso em
que, logo ao entrar,
são avisadas de que existem
essas 2 possibilidades.
Você pode atribuir o positivo
para você ou o negativo
para a outra pessoa, ou elas são
avisadas de que estão em algum
tipo de cenário em que
podem tomar a decisão.
Eu pedi a vocês, no guia de
leitura, para tentarem entender
o gráfico de resultados de Batson.
E o que eu quero fazer nos
próximos minutos é explicar
os resultados extraordinariamente
interessantes que surgiram.
Na 1ª condição, quando os
indivíduos são informados
de que podem definir as tarefas do
jeito que quiserem, 80%
– 8 de 10 – escolheram a
condição positiva para eles
e a condição negativa para o
outro sujeito. Certo?
Então, 80% das pessoas
fazem a coisa egoísta,
mas elas não consideram ter feito
algo particularmente generoso.
Elas se avaliam em 4
numa escala de 1 a 9, no que diz
respeito à moralidade.
E aquelas que atribuem a condição
positiva a uma outra pessoa,
se avaliam no topo.
Elas pensam que fizeram a coisa certa.
Agora, se você levar os
indivíduos para uma sala e disser
que eles podem jogar uma moeda,
mas que isso é opcional,
cerca da metade não joga a
moeda. E entre essa metade,
90% deles ainda se atribuirão a
condição positiva. Nenhuma surpresa.
O próximo número é o que nos dá
os resultados surpreendentes.
O que acontece quando os
indivíduos entram na sala,
são avisados de que podem
jogar uma moeda,
eles lançam a moeda e com base
na moeda uma condição
irá para eles e a outra
para o outro sujeito?
O que acontece é que, ao
lançar a moeda, 90%
acaba sendo atribuído à
condição positiva!
Agora, todos nós só temos
cinco dedos numa mão.
Então o que está acontecendo aqui?
Bem, vamos pensar sobre o que
aconteceria se você jogasse
uma moeda e desse cara? O
que significa cara?
"Ah, cara! Cara significa que
a condição positiva
será atribuída a mim e a condição
negativa ao meu adversário."
Dá coroa. "Coroa. Hah. Coroa! Isso
significa que a condição
positiva será atribuída a mim e a
condição negativa ao meu adversário."
Mas o impressionante é: 90% das
pessoas lançaram a moeda,
escolheram a condição
positiva e se avaliaram
como tendo agido de forma
extraordinariamente moral
– 7 numa escala de 9, no que diz
respeito ao comportamento moral.
E aquele cara que realmente
seguiu o lado da moeda,
se dá um 9. Tudo bem.
Batson está preocupado com isso e diz:
OK. Deixa eu ver o que posso fazer
para que nas moedas não
saia cara ou coroa.
Eu vou colocar num lado
"positivo para mim"
e no outro lado "negativo
para o adversário".
O que acontece nesse caso?
O que acontece é que 86% das
pessoas que jogam a moeda,
quando ela diz "negativo para o
adversário", sabe o que fazem?
O que você faria? Você a lança
de novo, até aparecer…
"Essa não estava valendo! A que vale é
– oh, oh, é a 14ª vez a
que realmente conta".
E essas pessoas, mais uma vez, se
classificam como tendo agido
de uma forma incrivelmente
moralmente adequada.
Mesmo quando Batson coloca
etiquetas coloridas,
para poder ver pela janela o
que estão fazendo,
o mesmo impressionante padrão
de resultados se repete.
Em 8 de cada 10, 9 de cada 10 casos, as
pessoas – dada a oportunidade
de mostrar a elas mesmas que se
comportaram moralmente –
farão isso, mesmo que o que elas
realmente tenham feito
seja se aproveitar de uma
situação ambígua.
Parece, diz Batson com base nisso, que
a preocupação das pessoas é
parecerem morais para elas mesmas,
e não, de fato, atuarem de uma
forma que seja justa.
Mas o que é possível fazer
para induzir as pessoas
a um comportamento moral pró-social?
Aqui está o estudo posterior
realizado por Batson.
Ele colocou os indivíduos envolvidos
no mesmo projeto experimental
numa sala com um espelho.
Se o espelho está virado
contra o participante,
sem que apareça o seu reflexo,
os resultados obtidos são exatamente
os mesmos que os anteriores.
Cerca de 85% das pessoas definem a
condição positiva para elas.
Mas se o espelho está virado para elas,
com o indivíduo encarando-o de
frente [e lança a moeda],
apenas 62% se atribuíram a
condição positiva.
Desculpe, se o espelho está de frente,
mesmo quando não jogam a
moeda, 62% se atribuíram
a condição positiva, ou seja,
que estão se comportando de modo
quase completamente justo.
E se elas estão encarando o
espelho e jogam a moeda,
se comportam em 50%: exatamente
como previa a possibilidade.
O que está acontecendo aqui?
Parece que o simples ato de
se sentir observado,
mesmo que seja observado por
você mesmo, é suficiente
para provocar um
comportamento pró-social.
E um estudo extraordinário,
realizado há 5 anos na Inglaterra,
nutre isso. Nesse estudo,
havia um sistema de honra
por colocar dinheiro num pote ao
beber café no escritório.
Em algumas semanas, o pote estava tapado
por fotos de flores.
Há flores, há flores, há flores...
E nessas semanas, quase ninguém
colocou dinheiro no pote.
Na outra metade,
o pote esteve tapado com pares de
olhos. E nessas semanas,
as pessoas doaram grandes
quantias de dinheiro.
Temos algo como seres sociais
que nos encoraja ao comportamento
moral quando somos ativados,
consciente ou inconscientemente:
é a sensação de estarmos
sendo observados.
Se você quiser completar a sua
tarefa sem procrastinar, coloque
um par de olhos no seu computador e
um espelho na sua frente.
Acreditem em mim.
A introspecção profunda sobre
a história de Giges
por Glauco em A
República de Platão é,
à luz da investigação
contemporânea, quase arrepiante.
Ele queria contar a história
sobre o que podemos esperar
de alguém que percebe que
não pode ser observado
– a história do pastor que encontra
o anel da invisibilidade e,
quando o coloca, toma o reino –
é a história que a
investigação de Batson narra
sobre uma inclinação em
parte dos seres humanos.
Há uma tendência preocupante,
pelo menos entre aqueles
envolvidos nessas histórias.
Ou seja, a antiga civilização grega
parecia sentir que isso soa verdade.
Os estudantes
universitários
contemporâneos
do Kansas parecem confirmar isso.
Quando pensamos em nós mesmos
não sendo observados,
é difícil agir em conformidade
com os códigos morais.
E a questão que repetiremos ao
longo deste semestre
– tanto na unidade sobre moralidade
quanto sobre filosofia política –
é como a sociedade pode ser estruturada
de tal forma que exista o
equivalente aos olhos em nossos
computadores e espelhos em nossa
sala para que possamos agir
de acordo com as regras que permitem
às sociedades proporcionarem
o tipo de estabilidade que permite a
prosperidade dos seres humanos.
Temos alguns minutos antes de encerrar
e queria saber se vocês têm
perguntas sobre a aula de hoje.
Dúvidas?
Estudante: Você poderia comentar
sobre as consequências da
[inaudível] moralidade,
você [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Bom.
A questão é, quando eu falei sobre as
consequências da moralidade,
eu restringi a discussão às
consequências para você,
coisas como a sua reputação.
E a pergunta é: e os outros
tipos de consequências?
E quando agir de forma imoral
causa dano aos outros?
Uma das coisas que vamos falar
na próxima semana,
e repetir na seção sobre justiça, é
a capacidade dos seres humanos
para a empatia e simpatia
e como esses recursos podem ser
aproveitados para ajudar
a fazer algum trabalho pró-social que
os espelhos e os olhos fazem.
Assim que, excelente pergunta.
Estudante: [inaudível] quando Glauco está
falando sobre isso, [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler:
Então a pergunta é:
quando Glauco está falando sobre isso,
ele só está falando sobre
questões de reputação?
Há uma coisa muito interessante
ocorrendo no Livro II de A República.
Glauco e Adimanto estão
tendo uma conversa
que Sócrates teve com Trasímaco no
Livro I, sobre a reputação.
Então isso é parte do por que
ela está sendo invocada
como uma razão.
Mas também, você vai ver, quando
Sócrates dá a sua resposta,
ela é sobre a integridade da pessoa
que age de formas morais ou imorais.
E o que Sócrates basicamente
vai continuar dizendo é:
"Pode parecer para você que
tudo o que importa
é o que você aparenta para os outros.
Mas, na realidade, quando você
deixa a sua alma sair de ordem,
quando você se comporta de
maneiras impulsivas,
insensíveis às necessidades alheias,
você será incapaz de prosperar."
E essa é a resposta que vamos explorar.
Glauco ainda não levantou
isso como uma questão.
Sócrates vai introduzi-la na conversa.
Bom. São 11h20. Espero que a
densidade da aula de hoje
não tenha assustado vocês.
Isso fica cada vez mais divertido.
E estou ansiosa para vê-los
na semana que vem.